when you look at something you're
looking into the past see this bowl of
petunias
what you're actually seeing is what the
petunias look like a tiny fraction of a
second ago that's because light has a
finite speed take this star it's light
takes 4 years to reach Earth so we can
only ever see it as it was 4 years ago
the further you looked out into space
the further back in time you see and
astronomers can use this to explore the
history of the universe space is full of
electromagnetic radiation
astronomers can detect signals from
nearby stars from other galaxies from
the gaps between galaxies and from
nearly the beginning of time itself all
these signals are from different
distances and therefore different times
but they all arrive at once it's kind of
a mess luckily astronomers have ways to
separate everything back out and one way
is to look for a special signal hidden
in the noise the 21-centimeter line
this signal is produced by the most
common element in the universe hydrogen
hydrogen atoms absorb an emit radiation
at a specific wavelength of 21
centimeters and because hydrogen's
pretty much everywhere
the 21 centimeter line should be too but
there's more
because the universe is expanding
electromagnetic waves stretch as they
travel across it the further away from
us something is the more the waves
stretch including the 21 centimeter line
so by looking for that faint signal and
working out how much it's been stretched
astronomers can start to put dates to
the waves they're detecting each of
these layers comes from a different
moment in the history of the universe
from last Thursday back to almost the
beginning of time
the radiation that has traveled the
farthest the oldest visible layer is the
Cosmic Microwave Background this is the
remnants of the first light that was
able to travel freely through the
universe after the Big Bang it spent
13.8 billion years getting here and it's
like an opaque wall beyond which there's
nothing to see next came the dark ages
when hydrogen atoms spread out through
space not really doing much that is
until the first stars formed and then
the first galaxies as galaxies grew and
merged they started to affect the
hydrogen atoms in the space around them
ionizing the atoms and forming bubble
like shapes which appear as dark gaps in
the usual 21-centimeter glow astronomers
are now building new telescopes
specifically to detect these faint
ionized bubbles from over a billion
years ago they hope that buried within
these signals could be answers to some
of the universe's great mysteries like
the nature of dark matter thanks to the
finite speed of light every time we look
up we see the history of the universe in
the blink of an eye and with the 21
centimeter line scientists are starting
to find the secrets hidden within
[Music]
[Music]